مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من النشره المفصله من
العربيه انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه
الخامسه مشاهدينا
امريكيه يكشف عن شحنه يورانيوم ايرانيه
هربت الى الحوثيين ووقع جزء منها بيد
القاعده
الله اكبر
صارخا للعداله وتصعيدا خطيرا
الاضرابات العماليه تشل حركه بريطانيا
احتجاجات لعمال القطارات والبريد والقطاع
الصحيه
وفي الخطوه ما قبل الاخيره نحو النهائي
الاخير احلى ميسي تواجه صلابه
اذا مشاهدينا كشفت مجله نيوز ويك
الامريكيه عن تهريب ايران شحنه من
اليورانيوم المخصب الى ميليشيا الحوثي في
اليمن تسربت اجزاء منها في ايدي عناصر
تنظيم القاعده لم ترد المجله اي تفاصيل عن
كيفيه وقوع اجزاء من الشحنه بيد القاعده
لكنها اكدت ان الشحنه يمكن استخدامها في
صنع اسلحه نوويه كانت صحيفه معاريف
الاسرائيليه قالت ان ايران سلمت مؤخرا
شحنه يورانيوم للحوثيين تسرب جزء منها بيد
تنظيم القاعده
والمزيد معنا من القاهره عبد الملك
اليوسفي المحلل السياسي اليمني اهلا بك
سيد عبد الملك بدايه لا اعلم ان كان لديك
اي معلومات اضافيه عما ورد صحفيا اي
تسريبات موجوده او معلومات متوفره تم
طرحها مؤخرا حول ان كان موضوع تهريب مثل
هذه الاسلحه
للحوثيين وبالمقبل ومن ثم تسريبها للقاعده
التحيه وتقدير لك يا اختي من السنون
المشاهدين الكرام بدايه عمليات التهريب
السلاح من ايران الى مليشيا لحوث
الارهابيه هي عمليات مظلمه اي شيء متوقع
العمليات الاستقصائيه التي قام بها صحفيون
امريكيون والتي نشر عن تسريب تهريب
مواد مخصصه من اليورانيوم الى الحوثيين من
من ايران هي تعكس طبيعه الفوضى والعشوائيه
في مساله تهريب اي شيء الى الحوثي همم
سيد عبد الملك حول تهريب اسلحه للحوثيين
ولكن ان تصل هذه الاسلحه بهذه النوعيه لهم
ماذا يعني وكيف تقراون مثل هذا التصعيد
فيما يتعلق بنوعيه السلاح الذي يمدده
الايراني الى الحسين
قد يكون المساله خلط مزيد من الاوراق في
ال والفوضى في المشهد العسكري والمشهد
الامني في اليمن والمنطقه نعرف انه لا
يشترط ان يكون اليورانيوم كامل التخصيب
حتى يستخدم في الاسلحه التكتيكيه وبالتالي
قد تكون ايران تمد ميليشيا الحوت
الارهابيه بالايرانيوم المخصب والليل ليس
مكتمل التقسيم لاستخدامه في اسلحه تكتيكيه
في صواريخ
مسيره همم امور كثيره الطبيعه التهريب
الذي يجري في طريق في طرق مظلمه عصبيه
مافيوزيه بعيدا عن عطر الدوله والقطر
بتعرف عليها في القانون الدولي والبرتقول
الدولي تجعل اي شيء محتمل ان تقوم به
ايران الارهابيه لكن الجديد في الامر هو
ما كشفه الصحفيون وهو الوصول الى القاعده
نعرف نحن في اليمن
بدنا نتحدث عن هذا الارتباط والعلاقه ما
بين الحوثيين والقاعده وايضا الانتشار
الجغرافي للقاعده ماذا يقول لنا عن كيفيه
وصول مثل هذه الاسلحه لهم تسريبها
لابد ان نعرف ان هناك ارتباط عضوي ما بين
التحركات تنظيم القاعده في جزيره العرب
الارهابيه خارطه النفوذ الحقيقي القاعده
في جزيره العربيه
مديريه قيفه ومديريه السواديه ومديريه
مختلفه من البيضاء هي تحت السيطره
الارهابيه هي مناطق النفوذ الاساسيه
للقاعده
والامريكان اكتشفوا في عام 2018 ذلك
التنسيق الذي كان يتم ما بين الامن القومي
الذي يدير يدار في صنعاء من قبل الحوثي
وما بين القاعده وتنظيم القاعده
والاجتماعات التي جمعت قيادات عليا من من
الصف الاول من الحديث الارهابيه مع قيادات
القاعده همم والذي اكتشفه الامريكان والذي
كان سبب اول تحول في الموقف الامريكي
باتجاه باتجاه من الاشياء الحديث
الارهابيه هذا التنسيق يدل ان هناك
وراء الكاميرا في قائمه مثلا عندما كان
هنالك جبها في قيفه يتحدث المقاتلون على
الارض والقاده العسكري على الارض ان
جماعات القاعده كانت تقاتل مع الحوثي جنبا
الى جنب همم في شبوه مثلا لاحظنا تخادما
كبيره ما بين من اللي همم القاعده وعناصر
القاعده مع مليش الحوثيين سواء تخادم
عسكري او تخادمه في المواقف في الاصطناع
المشاكل واختلاقها هذه المساله تعود الى
الى التنسيق الحقيقي ما بين القاعده
وقياده القاعده مع ايران وكان المساله
وكان ايران تحرك الحوثي وتحرك القاعده
كادوات من ادواتها لصناعه العموم لنقرا
المشهد الان من خلال حديث عن هذا التنسيق
هل انت تقول بانه قضيه ايصال هذه الاسلحه
للقاعده كان مقصودا باوامر بمعنى اخر او
انه لا ربما جماعات معينه هي التي تتواصل
مع هذه القاعده لاصال مثل هذه الاسلحه لها
القرار الاستخباراتى والعمليات في صنعاء
وفي صعده لا يمكن الحوثيون هم الذين
يملكوا سنه وهم ضباط المخابرات الايرانيه
وعناصر حزب الله هذا ما يعرفوا الذين
يعرفون تفاصيل ما يجري في صنعاء وبالتالي
التنسيق القائم ما بين القاعده والحوثي
وليس بتنسيق حوثي وانما هو بتنسيق باشراف
ايران وبالتالي همم
قد تكون الامور ان ايرا قررت ايصال هذه
الاسلحه للقاعده لكن هذه المساله قد تعني
تطور خطير في استراتيجيات صناعه العنف
والفضه في المنطقه يستدعي بلوره
استراتيجيه المواجهه قد يكون هنالك امرا
ما تريده ايران في المنطقه من خلال تنظيم
القاعده بعيده عن الحوثيين هذه الامور
كلها متوقعه خصوصا انه مشروع ايران في
المنطقه هو ليس مشروع فقط تمدد ونفود هو
مشروع قائم على صناعه الفضه بالتالي
القاعده واحده من افضل الادوات لصناعه
الفوضى يعني والاكثر قدره على صراحه
افعلوا ان تفعله هو وتقوم به القاعده لا
يستطيع الحوت ان يفعله
ربما كانت المساله من خلال اجنحه القاعده
في دول اخرى ربما اشهد عمليات ارهابيه
تنفذها القاعده في الدول الاخرى من دول
الجوار مثلا بعيدا عن النفوذ الحوثي خصوصا
القاعده لها لها ادواتها وخلان نائمه في
بعض الدول ربما تكون المساله كبعد استراتي
تريد ايران والمخابرات الايرانيه لصنع
فوضى معينه في منطقه معينه المساله كلها
في التعامل مع ايران ومشروع تصدير الفوضى
الايراني كله الاحتمالات وارده ولا بد من
استراتيجيه مواجهه همم بعمل استخباراتى
مضاد همم اجهاض اي عمليات ارهابيه قادمه
قد تقوم بها جماعه القاعده او الجماعات
التي تديرها النظام الملاهي في يطهرن لانه
القاعده اثبتت الايام انها لم تكن سواء
دواء اداء من ادوات النظام القاهره
السياسي اليمني شكرا جزيلا لك
تحدثنا عن ايران والدور في ما يتعلق
بالحوثيين الان الى الداخل الايراني
وتحديدا الى الاحتجاجات في ايران وايضا
ردود الفعل الدوليه الغاضبه والمهدده
لاعدام ناشطين وصفت منظمه الدوليه عمليات
الاعدام التي ينفذها النظام في ايران طبعا
بحق المحتاجين بالانتهاك الصارخ للعداله
والتصعيد الخطير للوضع المنظمه حذرت في
تقرير عن تفاصيل اعدام الشابين محسن شكري
ومجيد رضا طبعا من ان عده اشخاص اخرين في
خطر الان الباحث الايرانيه البارزه في
هيومان رايتسو
هاري قالت ان المتهمين يتعرضون للتعذيب
للاعتراف بتهم لما يرتكبها الباحثه
الايرانيه قالت انه وفقا للتقارير فانه
يتم الاحتلال على الضمانات المنصوص عليها
في القانون الجنائي وقانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه الايراني
وصفت في تقريرها الاحكام الصادره عن
القضاء كالافساد في الارض والاحراب
بالاحكام الغامضه وشددت المنظمه الدوليه
على ان المحاكمه التي وصفتها بالمتعجله
والتي حرمت المتهمين من الاتصال بمحامنا
من اختيارهم هي بعيده كل البعد عن
المعايير الدوليه وقد اصدرت محاكم النظام
ما لا يقل عن احد 10 حكما بالاعدام على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات بحسب المنظمه التي توقعت
ايضا ادانه العشرات من بينهم اطفال بتهم
قد تؤدي الى عقوبه الاعدام
المزيد معنا من لندن البحث في الشان
الايراني اهلا بك سيد حسن بدايه القراءه
في عمليه الاعدام بصوره عامه هل هي رساله
تحذير تخويف للمتظاهرين بمعنى اخر
للداخل الايراني او لا هي استفزاز للخارج
تحيه طيبه لك المشاهدين بالتاكيد هذه
الرسائل التي يريد يبعث بها النظام
الايراني ذو ابعاد عديده الى الداخل هو
بالتاكيد تخويف
ورعيب يعني المحتاجين
وبالخارج ايضا هي بانه نحن لا نبالي في
العقوبات وفي الضغوط التي تمارسونها ويعني
بالتحديد اوروبا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
لكن ايضا انه ليس فقط الاعدامات التي يعني
يكون فيها النظام الايراني بل هناك يعني
ادوات عديده لقتل المحتاجين يعني لدينا
قبل يومين همم كان الشعب من مدينه السوس
في الاحواز المنصوري بعد احتفاله واطلاق
صراحه
مات بظروف قام وبعد النظام الايراني
ينتحها وهذا ايضا تكرر في هذا البيتان
ايضا شاب بعد اطلاق صراحه قام بعمليه
انتحار هذا التعذيب النفسي
واعطاء المخدرات والهلوسه وضرب كرامه
الانسان بادوات عديده يجعل يعني ادوات
الموت متعدده من الانتحار من القتل تحت
التعذيب من الاعدامات من قتل بالرصاص في
الشوارع كلها يعني النظام
ولكن طريقه التعاطي مع هذه الخروقات
وبالتالي ما هي الخيرات الاخرى ام المزيد
من العقوبات مطلوبه وطبيعتها
يعني الصوره واضحه انه النظام ايراني
سيعدم وسيقتل المزيد هناك العشرات في
قائمه الاعدامات تكلمت او كتبت صحيفه جوان
التابعه لحاسه الثوره الايراني انه هناك
اكثر من اكثر اكثر من 60 شخصا ينتظرون
عقوبه الاعدام وايضا كما قلت انه ايضا قتل
باسبب ادوات عديده اذا المجتمع الدولي
الدولي الامام هذه الصوره المزيد من
القتل والمزيد من الاعدام هذه العقوبات لم
ترجع اما يطور المجتمع الدوليه يعني ادوات
الضغط حتى تكون رادعه اما يعني يترك الامر
والنظام ايراني يقوم بماء يريد وهو الان
منذ 43 عاما العقوبات وادوات الضغط التي
تمارسها الدول الاوروبيه وامريكا على
ايران لم ترجع النظام ايراني انا اعتقد
انه يعني هناك ضغوط يعني التي تتعرض الدول
الغربيه من قبل منظمات الغورزان منظمه من
قبل النشطها هناك مظاهرات عديده في كل
الدول الغربيه انا اعتقد سيد صاعد تصاعد
الدول الاوروبيه فالضغط على ايران لانه
ليس فقط ملف الاعدامات وانتهاكات غورسانا
هناك ملف النووي ايضا سيشكل خطر كبيرا على
المجتمع
الارهابي ايراني غير ذلك من الامور التي
ايضا همم عذرا في ملف اخر نشاهد العواج
الرئيس وزراء اوكرانيا ردا على سؤال
العربيه يقول انه يجب محاسبه ايران على
تورطها في الحرب وهنا نتحدث عن المسيرات
التي تباع الى روسيا اي الملفات انت ذكرت
ملف الضغوطات ملف الملف الايراني والان
نتحدث عن ملف جديد اي هذه الملفات هو
الاقوى بيد الغرب الذي يمكن من خلاله
الضغط على ايران
اعتقد ملف التداخل الايراني في يعني في
الدول في القرين او في الحرب الالكترونيه
الروسيه هذا ملف خطير جدا بمعنى انه ايران
اعلن الحرب على اوكرانيا بشكل غير مباشر
وعندما يعطي الصواريخ وايضا المسيرات هذا
انه ايران مشاركه في هذه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان ايضا ملف خطير ملف انه ايضا ملف
خطير جدا
على سيد حسن اي ورقه يمكن الاستفاده منها
اذا ما صح التعبير غربيه
للضغط اكثر على ايران من هذه الملفات
وقضيه الاسلحه في اوكرانيا اذا ما اخذت
مسار همم على المحافل الدوليه هل لها
تاثير ايضا او لا
بالتاكيد الهاتف اكيد يعني تدخل ايران في
اوكرانيا هو الملف الاهم بيد القارب
وتعتبر ورقه مهمه للاستفاده منها الى رجع
ايران ودورها يعني المزعزع للامن واستقرار
ليس في المنطقه في العالم كما انه الملف
النووي ايضا مهم
بغاه 100
التدخل الكريمي في الحرب الالكترونيه لانه
ايران مقبل على صنع قنبله نوويه وهذا ايضا
ليس يهدد اوكرانيا فقط بل يهدد العالم
اجمل اذن هناك العديد من يعني التلفات
والاوراق بيد الدول الغربيه ونحتقد امامها
وملف السلاح النووي الايراني
اجرت الولايات المتحده تجربه اطلاق صاروخ
فرد صوتي وهو الذي تتجاوز سرعته الصوت
بخمسه اضعاف تم استخدام قادفه من نوع بي
بعد يوم تتنافس فيه الدول باسلحه تضرب
سرعتها باضعاف سرعه الصوت اختراق الجدار
الامريكي
الصاروخ تم اطلاقه من قاذفه بي 502 لتفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت بخمسه اضعاف رغم ذلك
يستطيع الصاروخ الفرد صوته ايصال شحنات
النوويه بدقه عاليه الى الهدف عدا عن
قدرته على التحليق على علو منخفض والمرونه
في تغيير الاتجاه كلها مميزات تجعل من
الصعب اعتراضه ما يرفع امكانيه اصابه
الهدف بنسبه كبيره
التجربه الامريكيه جاءت في اطار برنامج
الولايات المتحده للاسلحه الاسرع من الصوت
والتي قامت بتجارب سابقه على مثل هذه
الصواريخ
وبين الصين وروسيا رغم ان الصاروخ الصيني
اخطاء هدفه
عام 2001 2020
فيما دخلت كوريا الشماليه خط الاسلحه
الخارقه مؤكده انها اجره تجاربها ايضا
تجارب دفعت الولايات المتحده الى التحذير
من هذا النوع من الاسلحه والتي لا تلتقطها
اجهزه الاستشعار ما يخلق تهديدا خاصه مع
قدرتها على حمل رؤوس النوويه الى عمر
العربيه
الخامسه ولا كان بعد قليل
خلافات اوروبيه حول وضع سقف لسعر الغاز
ورئيسه وزراء ايطاليا تؤكد ان الاجراءات
المتخذه غير كافيه
بلدنا فيها شيء يميزها يا سيدي على لمه
اهل الحجاز لقمه منتهى على سفرتهم ولا
الحمير تحت غيوم الجنوب ووسط جبالها والله
على صحن جديد يجمعنا في نجد الاحباب وما
تدري تندبح اللمه ولا المكبوس ما نسمه على
بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعام المميز
حاضر معنا فيك الجمعه الحلوه
بنيناها معكم يوم بعد يوم
بنيناها بالتربيه الصح
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
دجاج اليوم
طازج بكل ثقه تنطلق فعاليات المؤتمر
السعودي العاشر للشبكات الذكيه برعايه
وزاره الطاقه من 12 الى 14 من ديسمبر 2022
وذلك بفندق هيلتون الرياض تحت شعار حلول
تكامليه لطاقه مستدامه فكن جزءا من هذا
الحدث الهام وبادر بالتسجيل من خلال زياره
الموقع الالكتروني للمؤتمر
الرعايه الاعلاميه الحصريه العربيه
دور جديد يلعب قطاع السياحه في الاقتصاد
السعودي باستداف توفير مليون وظيفه جديده
وتسجيل 100 مليون زياره سنويه في 2030
بحسب رؤيه المملكه اليوم وبعد تسجيل 62
مليون زياره للمملكه في 2021 والمساهمه في
اكثر من 5% من الاقتصاد السعودي فكيف يمكن
للسياحه ان تساهم بعشره في المياه وكيف
تصبح السعوديه وجهه عالميه السياحه
السعوديه ضمن الاسواق العربيه يلا نبي
نصحصح النبي الاكل ابداع جهزي العده وافرد
الخمسه
وين العجينه حط اللبنه والزعتر رشيه ايوه
بالضبط فيها شويه سمان
الله والخيار قطعيه ايوه غمسيه يا سلام
عليك يا فنانه
كل فخر صنعت في السعوديه لبنه المراعي
الفاخره طعمها يبيض الوجه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه عيد ميلاد
افتراضي على غرار عيد الميلاد اثناء
الوباء هو التوصيف الانسب للحاله التي
ستمر بها بريطانيا خلال عطله الاعياد
القادمه
قطارات لن تدور على السكك لايام لتتوقف
اهم سبل النقل التي تعتمد عليها المملكه
40 الف عامل في القطاع واربعه عشر الف مش
شغال او 14 مشغل قطارات مضربون عن العمل
بدءا من اليوم وحتى السبت المقبل رساله ما
فاتها بكل اختصار نريد شروط افضل للعمل
واجور اعلى والا ستستمر الاضرابات حتى
يناير المقبل ايضا اما السيناريو الاسوء
للاسباب ذاتها في يجري في المشافي التي
اوقفت استقبال المرضى فلا ممرضات في
الخدمه 100 الف ممرضه في 76 مشفى ومؤسسات
تابعه لخدمات الصحه الوطنيه اضربنا عن
العمل وذلك لاول مره منذ اكثر من قرن
مطالبات بزياده الاجور بنسبه 19% قبلت
بالرفض من قبل رئيس الوزراء الجديد ريشي
سوناك قائلا انها غير معقوله فيما ينتظروا
400,000 مريض في بريطانيا دورهم لاجراء
عمليات جراحيه سيعاد جدوالتها وتاجيل 1500
منها بدءا من الاول ومن الاول وال 21 من
ديسمبر وحتى اشعار اخر تعطي العام لا عطله
ميلاد فحسب ستجبر المواطنين على التزام
منازلهم لتواجه حكومه سوناك احد اصعب
تحدياتها على كل المزيد معنا من لندن
الصحفي محمد شباره اهلا بك استاذ محمد
بدايه هل لك ان تعطينا وصف لما يحدث الان
من اضرابات في بريطانيا
يعني بالاكيد كما يعني وصفكم كان دقيق
للغايه يا استاذه ميسون ويمكن اضافه الى
اللائحه التي ذكرتموها ان القابلات
القانونيات ايضا ربما سينضم
ستنضم هذا القطاع ايضا والعمال فيه الى
الاضراب ايضا في المرحله المقبله
النساء لديهم مشكلات خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالاجور مقارنه بالرجال او انه هو اضراب
عامه
القطاع يعني
القابله القانونيه ايضا انضمنا الى
الاضراب ايضا ليس فقط لاسباب انه النساء
ام الرجال ليس هذا هو الامر لان كنت حابه
افهم هاي النقطه تحديدا بمعنى نساء ولا
همم قطاع التمريض بسرعه عامه قطاع التمريض
عموما استاذ ميسون اكثر من 100,000 الرقم
دقيق همم هناك ولي يعني هؤلاء من شاركوا
في التصويت وكان يكفي نسبه 50% من هن كي
يقام الاضراب هناك اكثر من من مليون ربما
ممرض وممرض عاملينها في هذه القطاع ليس
اغلبيتهم ربما منضمون ضمن النقابات ولكن
همم المنضوين في النقابات قررنا وقرر هذا
القطاع والمشرفين عليه الذهاب الى الرب
بعد ما رفضت الحكومه التوسط بينهم وبين ال
همم الاداره المشغله همم في قطاع الخدمات
الصحيه البريطانيه ولكن كما ذكرت انه
الشتاء الغضب في بريطانيا على كل
المستويات والنصيحه كما ذكرت ايضا في
بريطانيا لا اعياد يعني فعليه هذا العام
فالاضات تعصب بالبلاد في كل مناحي الحياه
والسبب هو تعنتننت الحكومه وربطها التوسط
بين ارباب العملين
فدائن وبدلاء اذا ما صح التعبير هل هذا
ينجح انا اعتقد البدلاء والبدائل
المستخدمه هي عندما يعني اشتهرت بها هذه
الحكومه كل ما جرى اي حادث ماء وتعني همم
تاخر اي قطاع عن الاعطاء والانجاز في حاله
الطوارئ استدعوا قوات الجيش ليقود همم
يعني همم
العسكريون بعض السيارات الاسعاف او ان
يحلون محل رجال وضباط الهجره والجوازات في
بعض همم
المرافق الحيويه ولكن لا اعتقد ان هذا همم
هذه الحلول همم تكون وافيه وكافيه الغضب
يتزايد من الحكومه
ورفضها بشكل انجيولوجي همم ان تجلس حتى
للتوسط بينك يعني جرى هذا بالامس همم رئيس
نقابه الممرض وصلت الى مقر 10 داونلود
ستريت استقبلوها همم عفوا الى وزاره الصحه
استقبلها الوزير لمده 20 دقيقه لم تفهم
ماذا جرى في الحديث او الى ماذا خلص
الاجتماع كل ما كانت تطالب به هو ان يتوسط
امام الاداريين لرفع مستوى الدخل قليلا
ليس بالمستويات الايطالب بها الممرضون
مثلا او الاطباء او عمال السكاك الحديد
ولكن نسبه كافيه ل- يعني همم
هذا همم الرفض لا وساطه لماذا لانهم غير
قادرين ليس لديهم القدره حتى على الوساطه
ليس هناك من اموال والضغط همم قوي جدا على
المستوى الاقتصادي عليهم وبالتالي غير
قادرين على ذلك
الاعتقاد الذي صار يعني واضحا لدى ارباب
العمل وايضا لدى النقابات هو تعنت
ايديولوجي ان سحب تعبير استاذه ميسون انه
هذا هذا العمل ليس من تدخل الدوله الصغيره
التي ينادي بها هذا الفصيل من حزب
المحافظين المسيطر على السلطه منذ ايام
تريزا ماي وبعدها بوريس جونسون ثم
الاستراس واليوم ريشي سوناك هؤلاء يريدون
ان يلعب السوق لعبته ولكن ده عيني اذكر
مثال للمشاهدين الكرام ان اا قطاع السكك
الحديث كان قطاع سيادي باعته حكومه
المحافظين بانتشر لشركات متعدده وتم تقسيم
هذه الكعكه بين الشركات خاصه كبيره ولكن
هذه الشركات ما زالت تستوفي بعض الرساميل
والميزانيات من الحكومه لتوفير هذه الخدمه
فهناك همم شكل من اشكال التخلف هذه
الشركات عن الايفاء بوعودها التي وعدت
حينما اشترت هذه الخدمه السياديه واليوم
الحكومه تدعم رب العمل على حساب الموظف
ولو تاخرت الخدمه ولو خرجت يعني العمل من
الخدمه
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
الى الملف الاوكرانيا قدر الرئيس
الاوكراني
بحاجه الى 800 مليون يورو على الاقل
مساعدات طارئه لتربيه احتياجات السكان
خلال فصل الشتاء تصريحاته ذا لانسكي جاءت
خلال افتتاح مؤتمر دولي للتضامن مع
اوكرانيا ينظم في باريس في قال عبر
الفيديو ان بلاده بحاجه الى عده فئات من
المعدات والمحولات وتربينات الغاز والى
مساعده طارئه من قبل نظام الطاقه
الاوروبيه
واحاول الطاقه وتحديدا ازمه الغاز في
اوروبا يتواصل الجدل بين الدول الاعضاء هي
لا وضع سقف لسعر الغاز رئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا جورجيا ميلون اعتبرت ان استجابه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
ليس كافيا يحدث هذا طبعا في وقت قالت
مفوضه الطاقه الاوروبيه في اجتماع وزراء
الطاقه اليوم ان الدول لديها وجهات نظر
ومخاوف مختلفه بشان تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز
واضافت ان علينا عليهم رؤيه مدى استعداد
الدول للتنازل بشان تحديد سقف لسعر الغاز
طلب من الجميع ان يظهروا نوع من المرونه
للتوصل الى اتفاق بشان سقف الاسعار
وقد صرحت بدورها رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسولا فاندر لاين بان العمل يتم حاليا
لتعزيز دعم قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا نتابع
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعمل على زياده كميه
الكهرباء التي يتم تبادلها بين اوكرانيا و
مولدوفا وبقيه اوروبا وهذا مهم لانه يجب
علينا ان نبقي الشبكه الكهربائيه
الاوكرانيه تعمل رغم القذف الروسيه لقد
قمنا في توفير اربعين مولدا كهربائيا
كبيرا الحجم لتوفير الكهرباء
لثلاثين مستشفى
وفي اشاره الى تزويد ايران روسيا بطائرات
مسيره قال لا وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
جيمس كليفرلاند كليفرز عذرا في لندن قال
ان لندن فرضت عقوبات على شخصيات ايرانيه
وروسيه ايضا رفيعه المستوى ذلك ردا على
هجمات على اهداف مدنيه باوكرانيا وصف وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه الاتفاقات بين روسيا
وايران والدنيا وقال انها تهدد الامن
العالمي
مجموعه شامله من اللوائح اقرتها الولايات
المتحده في اكتوبر تهدف الى تقييد صناعه
اشباه الموصلات في الصين وفي خطوه جديده
في ملف الرقائق الالكترونيه تخطط الصين
لضخ استثمارات جديده في صناعتها لتحقق
اهدافها في هذا المجال المتابعه
الصين تخطط لضغط استثمارات بنحو 133 مليار
دولار في صناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه في
خطوه لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي من حزمه
اشباه الموصلات والمواجهه التحركات
الامريكيه تستهدف ابطاء التقدم التكنولوجي
الصينيه وتتضمن خطط بكين اعفاءه ضريبيه
وحزم حوافز لمده خمس سنوات واعانات وقروض
لدعم الابحاث وانتاج اشباه الموصلات
خطه تقييد صناعه اشباه الموصلات في الصين
التي اقرتها الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر
دفعت وزاره التجاره الصينيه لاطلاق النزاع
تجاري في منظمه التجاره العالميه ضدها
موازنه عاليه جدا خصصتها الصين منذ
البدايه تضاهي تلك الامريكيه
فبكين تسعى من اجل رفع حصتها السوقيه
لتبلغ 70 بالمئه بحلول عام 2025 وان كانت
التوقعات لا تمنحها سوى 40 بالمئه كحد
اقصى
ونوهت مجله فرن افيرز انه ينبغي على الصين
انتاج رقائق متقدمه بجيلين او ثلاثه فقط
عن الشركات الرائده في تايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه لبلوغ هدفها المنشود ما يعني
انها ستحتاج الى ما لا يقل عن خمس الى عشر
سنوات للحاق بركب تطور التكنوجيه فبحسب
خبراء ابرز ما يعيقه تقدم بكين في مجال
صناعه اشباه الموصلات اعتمادها المفرط على
استيراد مستلزمات الانتاج من الموردين
الامريكيين والتايوانيين والكوريين
الجنوبيين واليابانيين الى جانب افتقارها
الى المعرفه اللازمه اذ لا تزال تعتمد على
المواهب الاجنبيه في المسائل التقنيه
مجابهه الفتحاتها الولايات المتحده بوجه
الصين منذ عهد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ليطفوا على سطح المحيط الهادئ صراع جديد
طرفه الاول تحالف امريكي اسيوي مع كوريا
الجنوبيه وتايوان واليابان لاقصاء الصين
من مستلزمات الانتاج لصناعه الرقائق اما
طرفه الثاني الصين وشركات التكنولوجيا
المحليه
خامسه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
لكن من المراعي اجود زبادي مع زبادي
المراعي كل الاكل
وظيفه جديده وتسجيل 100 مليون زياره سنويه
في 2030 بحسب رؤيه المملكه اليوم وبعد
تسجيل 62 مليون زياره للمملكه في 2021
والمساهمه اكثر من 5% من الاقتصاد السعودي
فكيف يمكن للسياحه ان تساهم بعشره في
المياه وكيف تصبح سعوديه وجهه عالميه
السياحه السعوديه ضمن الاسواق العربيه
قالت البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده
ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالمي
كم من هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق
كل يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه
واقتصاديه اصبح ما بين سطور اكثر من
السطور
ابعاد جديده تستدعي اسلوبا جديدا وتحليلا
ادق تصور مختلف لعالم يبدو اكثر تسارعا كل
يوم
11:30 على شاشه العربيه
يد الام يا ما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعرب المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
الذي استهدف فندق في كابول يتردد اليه
رجال اعمال
في الهجوم الارهابي كما قتل عدد من عناصر
الجيش والشرطه المتحدث الصيني قال ان
السفاره الصينيه في افغانستان طلبت من
الجانب الافغاني تكثيف الجهود لانقاذ
الجرحى والتحقيق بشكل معمق في الحادثه
وجلب الارهابيين الى العداله
وفي شان صينيه اخر اكد المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه على ان الوضع الحالي
مستقر على الحدود الصينيه الهنديه وان
هناك اتصالات مفتوحه بين البلدين من خلال
القنوات الدبلوماسيه وايضا العسكريا
المتابع
الوضع الحالي وعلى الحدود الصينيه الهنديه
مستقرا بشكل عام
ويحافظ الجانبان على اتصالات مفتوحه بشان
هذه المساله من خلال القنوات الدبلوماسيه
والعسكريه نامل ان يتحرك الجانب الهندي
والجانب الصيني في نفس الاتجاه وان ينفذ
بجديه التوافق الهام الذي توصل اليه زعيم
البلدين وان يلتزم بالاتفاقات التي وقعها
الجانبان وان يعمل معا للحفاظ على السلامه
حيث يستهدف توفير مليون وظيفه جديده بحلول
20 30
الدور الجديد لقطاع السياحه السعوديه لا
يقتصر على زياده مساهمته في الاقتصاد فحسب
حيث يمتد الى سوق العمل وتوفير وظائف
نوعيه جديده للسعوديين من مستحدثات القطاع
توفير مليون وظيفه مستحدثه بحلول 2030
ولكن كيف من الممكن تحقيق ذلك حسب بعض
التقديرات فان قطاع السياحه سيوفر وظيفه
من كل ثلاث وظائف في السعوديه خلال
السنوات ال 10 المقبله مع تركيز المملكه
على النهوض بالانشطه غير النفضيه
قد تبدو النسب كبيره لكن سوق العمل في
القطاع السياحي يشمل مجالات اوسع مما
يعتقده كثيرون
فبحسب تصنيف منظمه السياحه الدوليه فان
القطاعات التي تتبع منظومه السياحه هي
منشات الايواء والحركه السياحيه وخدمه
الطعام والمشروبات والنقل بكافه وسائله
وتاجيل معداته ووكالات السفر والحج
والانشطه الرياضيه والترفيهيه اضافه الى
النشاط الثقافي وقطاع التجزئه
هناك 14 برنامج اساسيا في السعوديه لتنميه
القدره البشريه في القطاع السياحي حيث
تتنوع هذه البرامج لتشمل مختلف جوانب
العمل من المشاريع الصغيره ورياده الاعمال
الى المنشات الضخمه في القطع
وقد تم في يونيو الماضي اطلاق برنامج رواد
السياحه بهدف تدريب 100 الف شاب وشابه في
قطاعات الضيافه والسفر والسياحه وتتعاون
مؤسسات دوليه في توفير هذه البرامج مثل
جامعه لرش في اسبانيا وكليه اداره الفنادق
السويسريه وكليات الضيافه
وتهدف البرامج التدريبيه الى اعداد
المتدربين لوظائف المستقبل مثل ما ساهمت
مدرسه فرندي الشهيره في باريس في اتاحه
الفرصه للمتدربين الطهاره للحصول على
وظائف في اداره الفنادق المنشات حديثا في
العلا
وتمتاز العديد من هذه البرامج التدريبيه
بانها مجانيه بهدف مساعده اكبر عدد ممكن
من الشباب لتحقيق طموحاتهم في القطاع
السياحي
يستمر معرض العرض السعوديه الذي اطلقته
وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفاء في الرياض
باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض اذا احتفت من
خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراث
الثقافي السعودي
يستمر معرض العرضه السعوديه الذي اطلقته
وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفات في الرياض
باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض احتفت من
خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراث
الثقافي السعودي
وابرزت قيمته الثقافيه ومدى ارتباطه
بالهويه الوطنيه
اثناء زيارتهم للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهي العرضه الذي تتمثل
فيها نوعيه الشجاعه والنخوه
همم الرجوله ومدلولها الجميل الذي يدل على
الفزعه
واللحميه هذا يعني شيء نعتز فيه جميعا
يعني تعتز فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
سواء شمالها شرقها اربعه وهذا شيء جميل
جدا يعني وهي العرضه همم السعوديه تتمارس
في جميع انحاء المملكه العربيه السعوديه
العامه
السعوديه الى التعريف بها بوصفها فن
سعوديه اصيلا وتصحيح المفاهيم المرتبطه
بها اضافه للاحتفاء بها باعتبارها تراثا
ثقافيا عالميا غير مادي مسجلا لدى
اليونسكو منذ عام 2000 2015
قد الفهد العربيه
حلقه السلطات البرتغاليه عمل القطارات كما
اغلقت طرق الرئيسيه في العاصمه لشبونه
بسبب الامطار الغزيره التي اغرقت الانفاق
جرافه السيارات غمرت محلات تجاريه ومطاعم
في العاصمه حتى المسؤولون حث السكان على
البقاء في منازلهم وتجنب الذهاب الى
العاصمه تحديدا حيث ابلغت خدمات الطوارئ
عن 250
حادثه في لشبونه ومنطقه ستبال المجاوره
ايضا
وبهذه صور وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه نلتقي
غدا ونشره جديده مشاهدينا